so the topic of this video are the many
organelles found within cells there's a
lot to talk about so let's get started
first really just a question to punch
you know what parts do cells possess
that help them survive
pause the video think about it for a
moment i'm going to go ahead and proceed
okay so first of all you know cells need
to take in food
rid ways to reproduce and as a result
they need to have a variety of parts
that helps them perform their job and
there's really three main sections
within the cell the cell membrane of the
plasma membrane being the outer boundary
the nucleus it's pulsing right there in
the picture so we're talking about
eukaryotes in this video and third being
the liquidy interior the cytoplasm so
let's talk about that first the
cytoplasm
so let's start with the cytoplasm the
jelly-like material inside of the cell
and it's in the cytoplasm that most
organelles are suspended within the
nucleus ribosomes vacuoles mitochondria
chloroplasts endoplasmic reticulum the
golgi body lysosomes this is a list here
of some of the organelles that are
suspended within the cytoplasm
so underneath the microscope you can
actually see what is known as
cytoplasmic streaming
in this case those green circles moving
around in the cell those are
chloroplasts and they're floating in the
cell they're floating in the cells
cytoplasm and underneath the microscope
you can sometimes see this
but what does the cytoplasm really do
number one because it's made mostly from
water it helps to dissolve solutes you
know you might know that water is a
solvent and so things will dissolve and
break apart when in water and so solutes
like proteins and carbohydrates
they can dissolve
with the help of chemical reactions in
the cytoplasm and another function is to
help move materials around so the
cytoplasm actually plays a vital role
within the life of a cell
let's move on next to the plasma
membrane also known as the cell membrane
and first of all let's talk about its
composition what it's made from first of
all you can see a phospholipid bilayer
two layers of lipids one right one on
top of the other right now
and embedded within the plasma membrane
here's a protein channel
there are carbohydrates on the outside
of the of the membrane and embedded
within our cholesterol molecules to add
flexibility
and so the job of the plasma membrane is
really to allow certain materials to
pass and restrict the passage of others
notice carbon dioxide and oxygen are
easily passing through the phospholipid
bilayer
but the plasma membrane is
semi-permeable because only certain
molecules can do this
here's glucose
c6h12o6 it's just physically too big
to slip through the phospholipid bilayer
but our cells need glucose inside so
glucose can actually enter through the
protein channel that you just saw in the
animation so
there's a variety of ways in which the
cell membrane can bring in materials and
restrict others
well here is uh the the nucleus
flashing in the black box let's zoom on
and when we zoom into the nucleus for a
closer look uh let's talk about the job
you know what you're often told in
middle school is that it's the
headquarters of the cell it controls the
cell's activity but how does it do that
well it's because of what's inside the
nucleus
there are strands of dna called
chromatin
long strands of dna loose linear
versions of dna
and
you might know that dna contains the
active instructions to make a protein so
chromatin is the active form of dna
where it's actively being used to make
proteins and this is why we say the
nucleus controls the cell's activity
because the dna is used to make proteins
and the proteins function in a variety
of ways to keep our cells going
you can also notice that there's a big
spot inside of the nucleus labeled the
nucleolus we're going to see what its
job is is to make something called
ribosomes and that's going to be
important in a little bit
and in this picture here an electron
microscope picture you can see that's
the nucleus right there and you can see
the dark spot that's the nucleolus and
the nucleolus again creates ribosomes
and sends out the ribosomes and you'll
see what the ribosomes do in just a
moment
well let's go ahead and move on to the
endoplasmic reticulum and in the
flashing box you can see there's two of
them there's a rough and a smooth er
let's zoom in
and let's go ahead and talk about the
rough
er first notice in the picture here that
it's covered in dots circles labeled
ribosomes
and the ribosomes were crea or were
created in the nucleus by the nucleolus
and in this picture here you can see
there's the nucleus there's the
nucleolus and there's the rough er now
look at the nucleolus it's making some
black circles those are the ribosomes
and the ribosomes are being sent into
the rough er and the rough er is really
like a a network of tubes and tunnels
and the function of the rough er has
helped transport these ribosomes now
you're kind of seeing what the job of a
ribosome is is
they make proteins so the rough er's job
is to transport the protein making
ribosomes around the cell
and so a common analogy is that the
rough er is kind of like a subway you
know the people inside the subway would
be like the rough er they're being
transported around a city and in this
case the ribosomes are being transported
around a cell
and so if we look at the other
endoplasmic reticulum the smooth first
of all it's called smooth because if you
notice in the picture there's no dots on
it there's no ribosomes so the rough er
is covered in ribosomes and underneath
the microscope kind of has a rough
textured appearance but the smooth er
is
not covered in ribosomes and so would uh
you know reason to believe it would be a
smooth texture
and so the job of the rough i'm sorry
the job of the smooth er is to help
create fats and break down many of the
toxins that may enter into a cell so
really important in the overall life of
the cell
okay so let's talk about those ribosomes
we said they're created by the nucleolus
and there they are in the nucleolus
being created and they are they will
travel and be transported through the
rough er and that's what we see
happening in the blue area but what do
they actually do their job is to make
proteins let's explore that in a little
more detail
so here's a ribosome
you might know that a protein is made
from a collection of amino acids and so
there's a process that the ribosome
performs called translation and in this
process amino acids are gathered one at
a time and they're linked together and
so that's the job of the ribosome is to
gather these building blocks called
amino acids link them together and when
you link them all together you make
what's called a polypeptide
now you might remember from another
topic that polypeptides will twist and
fold and wrap into a final thing called
a protein but that's the job of a
ribosome is to build proteins and that
protein has a function somewhere within
the organism
okay let's zoom in to the golgi body
next and when we do there's the nucleus
there's the nucleolus the rough er and
in green there's the golgi body
now what we're going to do is we're
going to zoom into the rough er
and you can see there's the rough er and
all the gray circles those are ribosomes
and like we just said ribosomes will
make a protein and there's a protein
p-r-o-t-e-i-n
but this protein is not quite finished
it's an immature protein and so what
happens is a piece of the rough er will
actually enclose and pinch off and
enclose the protein forming what's
called a vesicle a protective organelle
and this organelle will carry the
immature protein towards the golgi body
so here's the golgi body and here comes
that vesicle carrying the immature
protein the protein will now be modified
and altered and finalized and become a
mature protein as it works its way
through the golgi body
and then
a membrane from the golgi body will and
i will enclose around the protein
forming another vesicle and this
protective vesicle will protect this
finished protein as it exits towards the
cell membrane
and here's the cell membrane here comes
the vesicle it fuses
and the protein
is
released to the outside of the cell and
can be used as needed by the organism
so if you notice a little assembly line
process the nucleolus makes ribosomes
the ribosomes move along the rough er
the golgi body sorts packages the
proteins
and then a vesicle will release the
protein from the cell
okay so let's do a little bit of review
pause the video and try to answer these
seven questions i'm going to go over the
answers right now
number one which organelle builds
proteins i hope you said ribosomes
number two which organelle stores dna
well that's the nucleus
number three which produces ribosomes
that's the nucleolus number four which
creates fats and breaks down toxins
that's the smooth er
number five which packages and releases
proteins from a cell that's the golgi
body number six which allows material to
enter or exit a cell that's the cell
membrane of the plasma membrane and
number seven which links chains of amino
acids together that's also a ribosome
number one and number seven it's the
same question just worded differently
so here's another review challenge place
these four steps in order from start to
finish pause the video because i'm going
to go over the answers in three two
one
okay so i hope you thought that step c
was first the nucleolus makes ribosomes
and then d the ribosomes exit the
nucleus and then b the ribosomes travel
along the rough er and create proteins
and then a the golgi body packages and
exports the finished proteins in a
vesicle
so we come to the mitochondria let's
zoom in
and here's a picture of the mitochondria
and here's an actual microscopic picture
right here
you know in middle school they tell you
that your middle school teacher probably
tells you the mitochondria it's the
powerhouse of the cell because it makes
energy what do we mean by that
well the job of the mitochondria yes is
to make energy but what it does is it
performs a process called cellular
respiration to create a molecule an
energy rich molecule called atp
adenosine triphosphate
let's talk about this
so here is the chemical equation of
cellular respiration now if you've never
seen a chemical equation before
there are some molecules on the left of
an arrow we call these the reactants so
in
cellular respiration glucose
c6h12o6 and oxygen are the reactants
they go into
the mitochondria
and then in blue here on the on the
right side of the arrow of a chemical
equation these are what are called the
products in other words what's created
what's produced and out of the
mitochondria comes carbon dioxide and
water and molecules of atp
now atp the reason they're flashing
right here because this is why your
middle school teachers tell you that the
mitochondria is the powerhouse the
mitochondria creates this molecule
called atp adenosine triphosphate
another day we'll talk about how it's so
full of energy
so kind of a interesting uh
side note here on the mitochondria it's
involved in the endosymbiosis theory and
so the mitochondria were once thought to
be a free living prokaryotic organism
and the reason we think that is it has a
lot of qualities of of a living thing
they have their own dna their own
ribosomes they make their own proteins
they can replicate this thing
almost acts like it's still alive
although today it's not a living
organelle
sorry it's not a living organism it's a
part of a cell it's an organelle
and so the way we think it happened is a
larger cell swallowed up the
mitochondrial ancestor
and the mitochondrial ancestor survived
and kept multiplying and reproducing
it's just trapped inside of the larger
cell that that swallowed it and over
time the largest cell multiplies and
divides into two
and you know you repeat this process and
over time they both become become
completely dependent on one another
and if you ask yourself well what
advantage would the larger cell have
with mitochondria living inside of it
the ability to make energy to make that
molecule called atp that's a big
advantage if you can make your own
energy you have a survival advantage
and then ask yourself well if you're
what advantage would the mitochondria
have living inside of the larger cell
well you'd have a home and protection
from other organisms so over time
they've both become completely dependent
on one another and this is known as the
theory of endosymbiosis
okay let's move on to the lysosomes
and if we zoom on in here's a cell with
a lysosome and there's little animated
scissors inside of the lysosome these
are symbolic of the digestive enzymes
found within a lysosome
and so the job of a lysosome
is to one break down food
so here's a protein so let's say that
this protein is uh swallowed up by the
cell and it goes into our lysosome or
that protein will be broken down into
the individual units or the amino acids
and then those amino acids can be used
by the cell in a variety of ways
well let's pretend that the cell is a
white blood cell another job of the
lysosome is to kill pathogens you know
pathogen is just the word for a foreign
disease causing
you know microorganisms like a virus or
a bacteria and so in this case a virus
has landed on a white blood cell a
little pocket begins to form and the
cell actually wraps around and
completely swallows the virus this is
the process known as phagocytosis where
a cell will swallow a large object
through the cell membrane
that virus is then placed inside of a
lysosome where the digestive enzymes
will destroy it so
lysosomes are very important in our
immune system's ability to rid ourselves
of infection
and a third process uh that the lysosome
performs is a process known as autolysis
or autolysis that uh and where it will
actually the lysosomes will actually
destroy a dying cell let's pretend this
cell right here is an aging dying cell
the lysosomes will release their their
animated scissors here their digestive
enzymes and this dying cell will be
destroyed and then a healthy neighbor
can multiply make a copy of itself and
kind of fill that space to help the
overall organism continue to survive so
very important organelle the lysosome
okay in the black box here we have the
centrioles let's go ahead
and zoom on into centrioles these are in
animal cells only
and so if we zoom out into centrioles we
can see that they are cylinder shaped uh
it's a cylinder-shaped organelle made
from proteins known as microtubules
and the job of the centrioles is to help
separate dna to opposite ends of the
cell when they divide when cells do a
process known as mitosis
so let's watch what centrioles do here's
a cell that's about to divide watch the
dna in the middle cells will copy their
dna and then the centrioles will
duplicate themselves
the centrioles then move to opposite
ends of the cell and little protein
fibers called spindle fibers grow out
from the centrioles and attach
themselves to the dna of the cell
and then the spindle fibers begin to
pull the dna
to opposite ends of the cell
and eventually once the dna is pulled to
opposite ends
then the cell begins to pinch inward
and ultimately
there are two cells so the centrioles
play a really important role in
separating the dna of
a dividing cell
during mitosis
okay so let's now talk about the
cytoskeleton and in this picture you can
see in a variety of locations there are
these little fibers these little threads
uh that are all throughout the cell and
these are the cytoskeleton a network of
protein fibers that crisscross the cell
and the job of the cytoskeleton
is number one to help give the cell some
shape they it adds internal support
you know much like the framing of a
house adds
support internally inside the walls of a
house
and in this picture here there are three
cells and this is a great picture
the three cells in the blue area shows
the cell's
nucleus the green area shows all the
mitochondria and the red area shows the
cytoskeleton and you can see how the red
fibers criss-cross
throughout the inside of the cell to
help give these cells shape and internal
support
okay so another function of the
cytoskeleton well first of all here's
the cell membrane that we talked about
earlier and notice the cytoskeleton
also provides tracts for molecules to
move along so molecules will move along
the tracks of the cytoskeleton as they
enter
or as they exit a cell and move around
within the cell
kind of a fun thing to google and look
around are these fun little proteins
called motor proteins because they're
proteins but but they actually look like
they walk
along the cytoskeleton and they usually
carry food molecules organelles or any
other molecules that the cell might need
but what these motor proteins are
walking along are the tracks of the
cytoskeleton so a very important
function
is help molecule movement
all right let's do two organelles on one
slide here the cilia and the flagella
they both have a same a similar function
if cells are capable of movement it's
because of the actions of either cilia
or flagella
so let's talk about cilia first let's
zoom on in
and you can see these little hairs let's
zoom in even closer
and you can see that these cilia are
little tiny short hair like extensions
they're
incredibly numerous way too many to
count there's no way to ever be able to
count them there's just so many of them
on one cell and and they wiggle back and
forth and helps the cell propel itself
through its liquidy into uh its liquidy
environment that it might be living in
so here's a picture of a microscopic
organism
this one the cilia uh
will actually
beat in a rhythmic circular manner to
draw
a food inside of it and so even though
the the cell doesn't swim around this
cell is anchored into place it uses its
cilia to kind of create a current to
bring in uh
you know molecules for it to
eat so let's look at the flagella next
well first of all in this picture here's
an egg cell and here's a sperm cell
notice the sperm cell has a long tail
that's called the flagellum which is
singular flagella being plural so the
flagella or flagellum is a long
whip-like extension it whips back and
forth and helps the cell swim
now notice in this picture
right here of e coli bacteria the the e
coli actually have more than one
flagellum some cells may only have one
flagellum others may have more than one
point is there's not that many of them
compared to the cilia which are more
numerous
okay let's talk next about the cell wall
outermost layer of plants fungus and
bacteria cells now the cell wall of
plants and fungus and bacteria are not
the same the cell wall of plants is
different from the cell wall of fungus
the cell wall of fungus different from
the cell wall of bacteria
but these types of organisms do have
what's called a cell wall
let's talk about plants so here's a
plant cell and in yellow is the cell
membrane or the plasma membrane and in
green is the cell wall
and the job of the cell wall had support
for growth
so on a historical note about the cell
wall it was first witnessed by robert
hook in 1665 using the microscope that
he that he created he sliced a real thin
piece of cork and looked at it
underneath the microscope and this is
the picture that he drew right here and
so he examined cork cells cork cells are
dead the only thing that he could see
was the outer boundary the cell wall
and the reason the the cell wall still
existed even though the cells are dead
is because it's made from a very tough
carbohydrate called cellulose but he
named these boxes cells because they
look like tiny rooms and another word
for a tiny room would be a cell
okay let's move on to the chloroplast
next
the job of the chloroplast perform
photosynthesis
well here are several dozen leaf cells
let's zoom in
and when we do we can see that you know
this is one
cell right here and inside there's
dozens and dozens of chloroplasts these
are the organelles that perform
photosynthesis
and in this animation right here we see
cytoplasmic streaming you can see the
chloroplasts are the green circles that
are floating around within
these plant cells here
and so here's a leaf and so this is
another example of a chemical equation
and as we said earlier the molecules
listed on the left of the arrow these
are the reactants
so what goes into photosynthesis is on
the left but the right side of the ear
are called the products and that's what
comes out of photosynthesis
so in this case the reactants what goes
into for instance leaf cells sunlight
water carbon dioxide these are the
reactants they go into the plant cells
and on the right hand side of the arrow
what comes out are the products in this
case o2 is oxygen and glucose now
glucose is the full purpose
of photosynthesis the plants are trying
to make glucose so they can feed
themselves the oxygen is just a gaseous
waste product
and as we said earlier with the
mitochondria the chloroplasts are also
involved in the endosymbiosis theory the
chloroplast
like the mitochondria
is believed to have once been a free
living prokaryotic organism and for the
same evidence that we said earlier with
the mitochondria chloroplasts also have
their own dna their own ribosomes they
make their own proteins and they can
replicate so they have many actions they
perform many actions that lead us to
believe that at one time they used to be
alive today they're not they're
organelles of plant cells
but we believe that they were swallowed
by a larger cell and they
survived and and multiplied inside of
the larger cell now the larger cell also
would grow and eventually multiply into
two
two cells and then repeat this process
and like the mitochondria over time the
chloroplast and the larger cell just
become dependent upon one another
and so what advantage would the larger
cell have with chloroplast living inside
of it well if you have a part inside of
you that produces food for you you have
an advantage and that's what the
chloroplast does is it produces food
that the largest cell can take advantage
of
well what advantage would a chloroplast
have living inside of the larger cell
again a home and protection from others
okay let's move on to the vacuole next
so here's a plant cell and this was this
is a plant cell's central vacuole now
the job
of a vacuole is to store food water
waste color pigments
also when filled it adds internal
pressure helps to support the cell from
the inside
and so in this picture here
notice how the vacuole is filled with
with uh with water and as a result the
leaves of the plant are are fully
supported
but in this picture the vacuole is
shrunken because this cell is not
receiving enough water and
as a result the leaves of a plant may
look wilted so you can kind of tell if a
plant needs more water
based on whether or not the leaves are
supported or wilted
and in a plant cell right here we have
again what's called the central vacuole
a large central vacuole stores food
water waste color pigments
you've seen this picture a couple times
throughout this video here
this is these are plant cells and the
green circles are the chloroplasts
moving around
the edge of the plants up but my
question to you is
and by the way this is known as
cytoplasmic streaming my question to you
is why are the chloroplasts only moving
along the outer edge of the plant cell
well the reason is because there's a big
central vacuole
that takes up most of the internal space
of the cell now you can't see it because
it's filled with water but it's there
and so for that reason the other
organelles are often pushed to the outer
edge outer boundary of this of the plant
cell
animal cells also have vacuoles they
store food and water and
waste and such the difference being that
they're just smaller and more randomly
scattered throughout the cytoplasm like
you see in this picture right here
and there you have it wow i know there's
a lot of information that was just
covered well here's a little practice
quiz i hope you find it helpful if
you're in my class i'm happy to check
your answers so thanks for watching
everyone i'll catch you on the next one